c'est pour la première fois sans l'ombre
de son prédécesseur que le pape François
a prononcé l'audience générale du
mercredi
[Applaudissements]
il a salué un grand maître de la
catéchèse un grand maître dont la vision
doctrinale conservatrice de l'église et
sa stature intellectuelle lui confère
est un poids important auprès de
nombreux fidèles j'ai senti un proche un
pape très humble très brillant voilà
très discret et très touchant et puis
c'est un pape très intelligent qui a
fait avancer la théologie dans l'église
et voilà pour toutes ces raisons et puis
pour lui confier notre église qui
souffre beaucoup je pense que c'est
encore comme un dessin dans le passé qui
ont qui vont faire avancer l'église de
là-haut parmi ceux qui défilent sur la
place Saint-Pierre aujourd'hui il n'y a
pas que des fidèles en deuil beaucoup
d'entre eux sont de simples curieux qui
profitent d'un passage à Rome pour
s'imprégner d'un événement historique
c'est beaucoup plus controversé que
d'autres d'autre pape
et donc c'est pour ça aussi probablement
qu'on était moins proches de lui
pendant les huit années de son
pontificat Benoît XV a défendu une ligne
conservatrice notamment sur l'avortement
l'homosexualité et l'euthanasie début
2022 Benoît XVI avait été rattrapé par
le drame de la pédocrinalité dans
l'église il a été mis en cause par un
rapport en Allemagne sur sa gestion des
violences sexuelles lorsqu'il était
archevêque de Munich
il avait alors demandé pardon mais avait
assuré n'avoir jamais couvert de
pédocriminel tout ça pesait lourd pour
Michel berner venue le 8 témoigner son
respect malgré tout il espère qu'avec
son départ c'est l'occasion pour un
souffle nouveau au sein de l'Église
c'est un peuple qui ne s'est pas fondu
et bien dans son temps donc le monde
évolue et
donc je pense que le monde peut être
effectivement et ben c'est au roi ou pas
au prince que c'est et ben c'est
d'évoluer aussi je pense qu'on avait
besoin de cela dans un monde qui ne
conserve fut un jour parfois même pas
les valeurs de la vie humaine le
cardinal Lacroix croix qu'on juge le
pape Benoît XV beaucoup trop sévèrement
après tout il a été le premier à
recevoir écouter et croire les victimes
d'abus sexuel dit-il
pendant 71 ans et va être 45 ans 25 ou
27 ans cardinal et presque 8 ans pas
jusqu'à l'âge de 85 ans faut le faire
alors ce service-là mérite d'être connu
à l'humanité un synode mondial en cours
une vaste consultation sur la
gouvernance de l'église permettra sans
doute de mesurer son évolution sur les
grands enjeux comme la place des femmes
la gestion de la pédocrinalité le
célibat des prêtres ou la situation des
divorcés remarié
c'est bien ce que redoute rien de
meunier avec la disparition Benoît
xvioureau de partout dit la française
arrivée à Rome ce matin et je pense que
pour moi il y a une page qui va se
tourner au niveau de la foi catholique
avec son départ avec son départ il ne
faut pas oublier dit-elle que c'est
Jésus-Christ le cœur de l'Église
catholique lui c'est un homme
célibataire